i managed to find a copy of neil
degrasse tyson's phd thesis and i spent
all week trying to understand it but it
wasn't easy to read because it's 370
pages long and theses are not intended
to be read by anyone but experts on the
subject so i became an expert on
galaxies obtaining a phd is the highest
academic qualification for someone
wanting to pursue a career in science
it's been a few years now since i left
my own phd to pursue other things
looking at tyson's success i thought
that his career path might have been
more of a straight line to get to such a
level so imagine my surprise when i read
that this thesis was not his first
attempt at a phd
his line was indeed more squiggly
he started as a graduate student at the
university of texas but felt that the
expectation to dedicate all of his time
to research meant that he had to give up
his other interests and the rest of who
he was
and some of the advice some of the other
advisors thinking they're doing me a
favor said you know you have this
personality why don't you become a
computer salesman i know some people who
work for computers you could be they're
trying to do me a favor by getting me
out of their community i said to myself
if i'm going to have to do a whole new
phd
it's not going to be at this institution
it's got to be fresh i might as well be
fresh in another place i want to read
his thesis to see what kind of
scientific foundation he had before
launching himself into a career in
science communication
to see for myself his contributions to
scientific research and to test myself
to see if i stand a chance at
understanding any of it for his second
attempt at a phd this time at columbia
university tyson took a stab at
understanding why the center of our
galaxy is the way it is
his thesis has the title a study of the
abundance distributions along the minor
axis of the galactic bulge it was
published in 1992
when he was 33 a phd thesis or a
dissertation is an account of years of
intense scientific research and it must
contain an original contribution to
human knowledge so what was tyson's well
let's have a look
chapter 1 opens with the quote it is
important not to worship what is known
but to question it
tyson then describes the galactic bulge
as a remarkable compact zoo of stellar
populations
let's draw a map of our galaxy the milky
way
this is a side on view with many stars
in the spiral arms of the disc
around the galactic center there is a
bulge with a high concentration of stars
this is tyson's zoo
perhaps the main attraction is a black
hole at the very center
astronomers can peer in at the black
hole our galaxy's fierce lion but only
from afar
there's a fear of being eaten if we ever
got too close but the sun and therefore
our solar system and us are out here
nice and safe held by the spiral arms
out there we have the halo comprised of
older stars and globular clusters
tightly bound groups of many stars
here's tyson's sketch of what he did
which is that he looked into the
galactic bulge along seven different
lines of sight to understand the
populations of stars in the zoo and how
they change as you get further from the
center
the chosen lines of sight are low
extinction windows through the plane of
the disk
so he looked through sections of space
where there wasn't so much dust and gas
in the way to obscure the stars these
are images of the seven windows and you
can notice the steep drop in star
density from the innermost bulge to the
outermost halo each window is named with
its latitude the smaller numbers are
looking further out towards the sparse
halo tyson measured properties of these
stars like their chemical abundance and
velocities to answer the following
questions
what is the abundance distribution
function at different galactic latitudes
within the bulge is there a smooth
transition in abundance between the
bulge and the spheroid or halo if not at
what latitude does the transition occur
and was the bulge's primordial gas used
completely in star formation or was it
expelled by ongoing supernova driven
winds
to measure the chemical abundance of the
stars tyson used the ciro tololo
inter-american observatory located in
chile
to get time observing on the telescope
he would have had to submit a proposal
maybe even a year in advance and compete
against all the other astronomers
wanting a turn
then he had to hope that on his
allocated days the sky wouldn't be
cloudy because if it is he won't see
anything
chile was chosen to house many
observatories because it is dry and with
little light pollution but every
observing run is still a roll of the die
tyson's first observing run was for one
night on the 7th of june 1989
to get to the telescopes is a long drive
up a bumpy scary road to an altitude of
2200 meters
up there the oxygen level is so low that
you might be out of breath just walking
around
so why would he go all that way for just
one night
perhaps he hoped to observe for longer
but got bad weather all i can tell from
his thesis is that he observed four
fields of stars that night and returned
a year later for two more nights to get
the rest tyson collected information
about his stars in the bulge and
processed that data to find their
colours temperatures magnitudes and also
their chemical compositions
he used the washington photometric
system to measure certain wavelengths of
starlight and look for absorption lines
these lines indicate that some of the
light that left the hot interior of the
star was absorbed by atoms or ions in
the star's outer atmosphere
some photons will be blocked from
reaching us and their absence reveals
what elements the stars are made of
it's not all smooth sailing though there
are plenty of errors in every step of
the process to account for
for tyson these included overcrowding of
stars in his inner windows causing some
of the light profiles to overlap
there was also the difficult job of
removing foreground stars from the
images
these both gave uncertainties in the
final measurements
there are many pages of data math and
nuanced details but tyson eventually
arrived at abundance distributions
which he said is the principal focus of
the study doing science means making
incremental changes to models of how
things work
tyson noted some existing models of how
galaxies chemically evolve and wanted to
see if his newly collected data from the
bulge matched any of these models
the simplest model starts off with a
ball of gas and all it can do is turn
into stars
no gas escapes
this is called the closed box model and
if you were to plot the metal content of
the stars against the number of stars
you would get a plot shaped like this
this is the abundance distribution
in astronomy a metal is any element
that's not hydrogen or helium
that's not how chemists would define
metals but in astronomy it allows an
easy distinction between elements like
hydrogen and helium that have existed
since the birth of the universe and
heavier elements that must have been
made by stars
stars make metals through nuclear fusion
in their cores
or in supernova explosions
supernovae release metals back into the
interstellar medium the space between
the stars
from which new stars with higher
metallicities may form
a variant of the closed box is the leaky
box which allows some gas to escape out
into the rest of the galaxy the
abundance distribution for a leaky box
would be the same shape but shifted to
the left the stars have less metal in
them on average than stars in a closed
box because those metal rich gas
explosions from supernovae are escaping
so let's take a look at tyson's
abundance distributions here's the first
of his seven fields the one closest to
the galactic center
he measures metallicity as the ratio of
iron to hydrogen and says there is
remarkable agreement with the abundance
distribution expected from the simple
model or a closed box he fits a
theoretical curve with a yield of 1.25
which is a measure of how much metal is
being returned to the interstellar
medium
the x-axis is scaled to the abundance of
the sun so zero would be the sun and one
is ten times the sun's abundance
going out further from the galactic
centre his next plot has the same shape
but is shifted slightly to the right the
error bars are quite large and he says
that this also fits the simple model but
with a higher yield
the third plot moving further out again
has a higher average abundance but he
concludes that so far the region from
the galactic center to
0.75 kilopasca
is a well mixed closed box
a parsec is a unit of distance but if
you're more familiar with light years
then this closed box region is about 5
000 light years across
the next few fields show a shift to the
left and a drop in average abundance we
might be seeing that the box is now
leaking or there's a more complicated
process at hand
but there are also not many stars being
measured here the last field out in the
halo only has three stars this is them
so he doesn't really have a lot of
statistics on his side here
tyson's measurements constitute the
first direct measurement of the galactic
latitude dependence of iron to hydrogen
in the galactic bulge
he shows that it initially increases
away from the galactic centre then
steeply drops off as you leave the bulge
this drop off occurs around one kilopast
away from the centre leading him to
conclude that those stars within one
kiloparsec followed a common evolution
he also concludes that the inner bulge
was not significantly enriched by infall
of gas and that the inner bulge
underwent no catastrophic mass loss from
supernova-driven winds
he finds that the inner bulge is
chemically distinct from the halo while
the transition region is a blending of
the two
astrophysicists care about these
questions because any new information
about the state of our galaxy helps to
refine all the models which try to
explain what our galaxy is and how it
got here tyson talks about the
implications of his findings for models
of how clouds of gas may have collapsed
to form our galaxy in the first place
there has been a lot more work done on
galactic evolution since this was
written in the 90s large-scale surveys
done by satellite and ground-based
telescopes like gaia and apogee have
been able to create maps of millions of
stars and dwarf the three data points
that tyson had out in the halo astronomy
moves pretty fast since every year there
are upgraded tools and methods of
observing
this thesis isn't tyson's only
contribution to research he has 13
research papers which all will have
contributed some new understanding
some of his papers are taken from
chapters of this thesis and his failed
previous attempt and i'll link those
down in the description because the
entire thesis as a whole can only be
found through the university of columbia
his combined work has racked up a bit
over 2 000 citations instances where
other scientists have used it in some
way
whilst this isn't extremely high it's
pretty clear that neil degrasse tyson's
main contribution to science is not in
his research but in his work as a
communicator his early research work was
his introduction to all the key workings
of the subject we can also take a look
at his acknowledgements page he thanked
the scientists who helped him along the
way he thanked his supervisor mike rich
for his encouragement and attention to
scientific detail
and dedicated the work to his family
he ended his thesis with a final thought
i have lived and fulfilled a dream yet
my life is just beginning
most of the notes i took and the facts i
learned about galaxies never made it to
the screen in this video but i really
feel that for this week at least i did
become an expert on galaxies even though
i might forget it all next week i found
this thesis surprisingly good at
covering a base of topics that one would
need going forwards to work in astronomy
or its communication and i suppose
that's exactly the point of a thesis
but then success is all about what you
do from here
this portion of the video is kindly
sponsored by skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of online
classes where members come together to
find inspiration and take the next step
in their creative journey for example
there is this excellent class by ali
abdal covering video editing with final
cut pro the class could take you from
having no experience to editing great
youtube videos
final cut is the software that i use to
edit my videos and even though i've been
doing it for a few years now i still
learned a few new tips and shortcuts
from ali's class joining this class
through skillshare is also much cheaper
than many of the other expensive editing
courses out there
in fact it can be free for you there's a
special link down in the description and
the first 1000 people to click it will
get a one month free trial of skillshare
so thanks skillshare for supporting my
channel and for helping people to try
new things
also a thank you to my patreon
supporters including today's patreon can
of the day
you